[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum ryan tayez is here
with me the beloved ryan tears yep i'm
here beloved did you uh you're beloved i
think that a lot of people out there
like you that's nice it is nice it is
nice i hope you're enjoying your week
guys i hope you're being good to
yourselves and uh thanks for listening
uh if you're tuning in here for joe
latruglio i hope you tune in and
subscribe to the podcast you can
subscribe
on youtube please and apple and wherever
else you get your podcasts the handles
to follow us on the because there's
always some fun information that bryce
puts out there or i put out there and
the handles are uh inside of you pod on
twitter inside of you podcast on
instagram and facebook that's correct
that is absolutely correct we've had
some great guests and some really great
guests coming up so i'm really excited
joe letruglio in just a second let me
just say a few things i will be at the
motor city convention motor city con
october 15th with tom welling doing a
smallville nights get your tickets now
online
uh also
um yeah we're gonna be doing a
smallville nights together um also
october 9th we'll be doing a stage at
playing a lot of music so if you go to
stageit.com
s-t-a-g-e-i-t-dot-com
rob and i the band sun spin we're gonna
be playing a lot of jams it's rob's
birthday so make sure you tune in
make sure you tune in you also get
tickets at
sunspin.com along with awesome merch you
can get inside of you merch at inside of
the inside of you online store there's
lex luthor stuff there's smallville
stuff there's
uh inside of you stuff and last but not
least my lovely patrons i love you uh
thanks for supporting the podcast a
little extra to help the podcast move
along just go to patreon.com
inside of you it's p-a-t-r-e-o-n patreon
dot com slash inside of you i'll write
you a message right after there's
different tiers there's different things
it's a wonderful community i really love
it uh joe latruglio fantastic just love
having him on the podcast he talks about
the final season and shooting brooklyn
nine-nine really exciting stuff and um
he's been in a lot of other stuff you've
probably seen his face and wet hot
american summer uh what did you love
mostly about this i just like his energy
i like what a great he's just a good guy
he is he's just a good funny freaking
dude and he's got some great stories and
i'm really excited about his new horror
movie that he's directing and we'll get
into all that so right now let's just
get into it let's get inside of joe
latruglio it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with my
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience joe this is a treat it's just
you know watching you pull up thanks for
uh having me again i i love having you
and you're such a great guest last time
and you know i know you've been
incredibly busy dude like you're you're
i i just love watching your career
because i i talked about this a little
bit before but
you're always the guy that was like oh
yeah you were that you had the one scene
in that or you had a scene in that right
yeah it was it was just kind of like you
were moving and shaking and going you
did the comedy truth to state and you
were always
and then all of a sudden
things just took off
yeah you know that's how these things go
i again i think we touched on this a
little bit uh last time is you gotta
find the right people you gotta
surround yourself with good people
people that are better than you and then
is that what you always do you surround
yourself by better people i try to
surround myself with people that are you
know more talented than i so i can raise
the game i think that's the
smart thing to do
you know
uh you know there's a mix of course
there's a mix right you can't always be
around people that are better but
i think it's an advantage
and it's a it's a way to improve
yourself
yeah well you know
we didn't really talk about this but you
grew up in florida i did i said florida
it's florida you say florida no i say
florida i do say florida but sometimes i
say florida but
what was that like were you like a
popular guy in high school um
no i would i wasn't unpopular i was i
rode the line between
being in the drama department which i
was and captain of the swim team which
is athletics but it's the swim team so
you were the captain
of the swim team yeah but you're a
swimmer i'm a swimmer i was a
backstroker but but because i was
involved in a i'm using air quotes a
sport it is a sport it's a sport i love
but in the high school vernacular in the
high school world swimming isn't you
know put on the pedestal did you shave
your body i uh narrowed it you narrowed
it i never doesn't dare burn the skin
yes i tried it with some of my back hair
once it didn't go well
um but i narred it yeah
uh is that for the aerodynamics
is that it's a hydrodynamics i guess
um it didn't work you know it didn't it
didn't add any it didn't take off any
time well you know what's funny is i
swear to god i didn't start puberty till
late like junior in high school i had no
hair under my arms so when we played
basketball because i grew up in indiana
and i i didn't play basketball much but
when we did like pick up games yeah
i'd always fear that i was gonna be um
not the shirts i was gonna be the skins
oh okay and then one time this guy mike
curry who had armpit hair probably in
fourth grade just harry henderson's down
there uh-huh i remember he looked at me
goes rosenbaum you don't have any hair
under your arms
dude are you serious you're in high
school and everybody looked at me and i
go oh no oh i'm a swimmer
oh
see that's what i mean immediately it
goes to uh i mean you didn't mean it in
a direct way i lied but you lied i lied
you know and swimmers aren't looked upon
uh as very valiant athletes in high
school but they're hairless so i got
away with that he got away with it i
kind of i was on my feet i kind of
picked that up said i'm a swimmer
i don't have hair and people bought into
it
so you did it you got five i did i got
by but you so you were you were so i was
oh i was somewhat i was i was like i was
not an unpopular kid um but people you
know it was a bit of a weirdo i was into
the
mad magazine and horror movies and you
know just it was a strange
lovely weird kid but um
was able to get along with most so and i
was funny that was the other thing so
you know that helped and your parents
were cool they were very cool they liked
what you were doing they accepted
everything they like didn't they think
you were weird that you were watching
horror movies no no they were always
very they were very supportive still are
yeah
yeah they were down with it i remember
like asking my mom like there's
something worth me i like blood too much
she's like no there's nothing weird you
just which which is to say like when i
was watching horror movies i loved all
the gore effects and i thought that was
weird that i was just obsessed with that
and i would you know and i'm like mom is
there something wrong she's like no
relax what is it though what is it about
you and i you and me
that we just you and i
is that any rabbit yeah that's um just
you and uh
now i'm playing
peaches and herb i think no no i think
they saying reunited croft maybe
i don't know maybe let's not but
what was it
what is it about horror movies that we
since we're a kid we want to be scared
for me it's the adrenaline it's like
going on a roller coaster and when
there's a good horror movie which there
aren't good horror movies out there very
there aren't very many yeah i get an
adrenaline i get scared i like getting
scared and that to me is fun is that
what it was yeah it was that i think
there was like the settlement of like
you're not supposed to watch this
don't watch this don't do it it'll scare
you that's you know that'll give you
nightmares
you know i think that was part of it and
also you know your kid you want to you
want to see some like action and
creatures and things that don't exist
and get scared i guess i don't know
i'm i'm literally armchair
uh experting this are you are you
because
now you fast forward to all this stuff
and you finally get to do i mean we'll
talk about brooklyn 999 in the final
season we'll talk about some other stuff
but like you get to direct
a horror movie this is gonna talk about
this is this a dream of yours to always
direct this movie it's called outpost
and you were talking about this briefly
last time i mean it's it's it's a hard
place to start i'm you know to give
context here i'm just
a week back from finishing this
project that has been with me uh
three years but has really been with me
you know
uh you know 37 years since i was 13
trying to make a horror movie so
uh
you know there's there's much relief
that like this thing is out it's out of
me i've got i've got this you know this
goal to have finally done a horror movie
and directed it uh and is kind of
out of my system and i feel
lighter and more relaxed because you
know i i accomplished something that
i've been wanting to do for a very long
time so there's that element of
achievement there and then um the movie
itself uh and the experience of shooting
the movie
is a whole other chapter of
um
joy and uh
like
um bonding with the with the people that
made it and uh
there's a lot of emotions mixed up in
just having shot this movie on a
mountain
which is very hard thing to do
[Music]
and
when you do something like that after
hearing so many people say
no
um and then you do it
you you kind of feel
pretty badass you kind of feel like well
uh i beat the odds i
beyond that i beat the odds like i beat
the odds but like i said what i was
gonna do
and you didn't think i was going to do
it and so there was a lit there's a
little bit of a ego
yes there's a little bit of an ego a
little bit of a chip that you know i
have to reel in but it's hard because
you just want to kind of show people
that it can be done you know um if you
find um
if you find the right people to do it
with and you really want to do it
um
it was just i was watching a documentary
about this financier of he was doing
like roger corman movies or i'm gonna
mess up the quote but the quote was
something like
um
movies
don't
don't get made because you
make them
they get they get made because you have
a boner to make them or something like
that it's like it's like it's such a
hard-on that i have to do yeah yeah i
messed up the quote but it's something
like i like your question it's a good
quote but it's like you know
that's the only way a movie's gonna get
done it's it amazes me that any movie is
made at any budget like the amount of um
of factors that can derail a production
is endless it's just endless and anytime
you know one gets made even if it sucks
i'm like wow man good for them they made
the movie they made the movie and you
don't really understand that until you
make a movie to your direct a movie and
then you have a respect for every
director who went out there and directed
not just every director but every person
that makes a movie so whether that's
from the the set pa to the upm to your
second a.d and you and you know i was
lucky enough uh to finance the movie
partly and once you paid your own money
yeah oh they always say don't do that
yeah i know but you know what they also
say like just keep trying eventually
you'll get the money and then guess what
happens and then your years go by and
you don't get the money and you're like
oh i did the same i wish i would have
done it yeah i put money by the way by
the way who's gonna bet on you if not
yourself yeah always bet on yourself man
right like no one else is gonna do it no
one else will do it so to me it wasn't a
waste of money because even if the movie
sucks even if um even if it doesn't make
a dime even if i was terrible at it i
would have been like you know what i've
been trying to figure out whether or not
i could do this whether i liked it
all my life and i did it and i spent a
lot of money but now i know that a i
don't want to do it anymore or b i suck
at it or c or whatever and that's that's
priceless so i got that info so to me
it was a i was a no-brainer that's an
easy that's an easy bet to put down
because that money is going to pay off
in one way the other either in your your
being able to sleep at night or before
you're dead you can be like all right i
did that years ago
that's that's just smart payment you
don't want to be 75 years old and say
why didn't i do that why didn't i why
was i scared why did i do it why was it
fear-based why didn't i i didn't do it
with the money because everyone said
don't put your money in and then i croak
i'm like oh because they said don't put
your money in how much money did you pay
did you shoot this movie we shot we had
a 16-day shoot it was an uh 89-page
script we averaged between six and eight
pages a day
we were um it was a 16 day shoot but we
were on the mountain um for seven days
and it was an hour up to the top and an
hour down so we really lost two hours
every day did you realize that before
you started in prep and you're like holy
[ __ ] okay yeah oh yeah no we did our due
diligence there but you know just to
brag a little bit more uh and both
because we lost two hours for seven days
that's 14 hours we lost we really shot
the movie in 15 days absolutely just go
with that i just wanted to yeah you did
yeah i mean it was a work day
um
i don't know i'm still so proud of
everyone that did the movie so i i can't
you know my um
dp is a friend of mine his name's frank
pereira and i've known him so i was 17
and um he he does a number of movies uh
from budgets like this to larger ones
and uh we've been wanting to do a movie
for a long time and he was with us from
the get-go and we worked you know a year
and a half on shot lists
and uh when we're on the plane back from
spokane we're just kind of shaking our
heads saying
how did how did we pull that off because
we um
we were very lucky there were no
injuries on a mountain that was 6300.
not only that but about the weather and
there were no weather events there were
no equipment failures wow there were no
ego problems on set there were no
um
thankfully no covet outbreaks there were
nothing and we boy are you lucky we were
we really were i i mean
you know but you would have figured it
out of course you would have figured out
if those problems did exist you know
what filmmaking is what is it solving
problems yeah it's problem solving it is
someone something you have to have a
boner for as i recall that's right it's
problem solving also someone else i
think one of one of my producers uh said
this also is like it's it's
problem-solving but also
throwing a party you gotta throw a party
and you gotta problem solve and you
gotta make sure it's a safe party you
gotta because you gotta make sure
everyone's having a good time
people gotta like the host
um so it's somewhere in between that
inside of you is brought to you by chirp
wheel chirp guys i you know i've talked
to you about this a million times but i
have trip wheels i have had back
surgeries and neck surgeries and chirp
wheel i use it every day no lie
this is a wonderful product i don't know
how many times i've said chirp wheel on
some moves i got one of those they're
awesome
they are amazing the chirp wheel is uh
where it's at ryan caught me chirping
uh last week in the living room chirp is
a brand dedicated to helping the world
feel good so they could do more of the
stuff they love in other words chirp is
all about feel good do more and to do
this chirp creates simple innovative and
effective pain relief prevention
solutions
chirp started with a revolutionary wheel
for back pain but they're just getting
started
what i love about chirp wheel is they
have this divot in the middle and it
fits your spine snug
comfortably and it's unlike any other
wheel you've ever had any any other
wheel to roll your back out this is an
exceptional piece
of machinery or uh
a piece of what ryan
uh
innovation hardware innovation hardware
chirp is all about helping people feel
good and do more back pain prevents
millions of us from feeling
our best when they don't feel their best
they're limited at what they can do what
we can all do chirp can help fix that
with chirps patent pending spinal canal
and three different pressure options to
choose from chirp will help your back
feel better so you can be back to doing
what you love in no time key features
that make this product stand out are
three different pressure sizes gentle
medium and deep
and i encourage you to get all three
wheels because the more you stretch on
the smaller one you'll be ready for the
middle one and so on uh it has a spinal
canal to comfort your spine as our
wheels give your back a unique four-way
stretch each wheel can hold up to 500
pounds they can be nestled together for
easy travel to take wherever you go
chirp is the real deal guys it's the
real deal give it a shot if you have any
kind of back pain you just want to
loosen up chirp wheels the way to go and
here's all you have to do you visit
gochirp.com
and enter the promo code inside to get
10 off site wide that's go chirp go
chirp.com and enter the promo code
inside to get 10 off site-wide inside of
you is brought to you by bright sellers
ah these guys are fantastic what a
delicious wine
that they manufacture
and i have them in my fridge right now
cooling off so after this podcast i
could just get a nice
glass of refreshing wine today's episode
as i told you is sponsored by
brightsellers if you have ever been
overwhelmed in the wine aisle and bought
a random wine you end up hating you're
not alone finding the perfect wine match
can be intimidating but it does not have
to be that's where bright sellers comes
bright cellars
uses a wine algorithm to match you with
wines
that you're guaranteed to love all you
have to do is take their 30 second quiz
which i took and they match you with
wines based on things you know you like
like your favorite type of chocolate or
your favorite type of juice it's that
easy they've really uh
been pretty incredible and innovative
and smart
to figure out what people like because
you go to a you know an aisle in the
grocery store and you get a bottle of
wine these guys
break it down what things do you like
and then they know okay he wants a
sweeter wine oh he wants something like
this uh it's pretty amazing ryan want
you tell us some more stuff each wine
also comes with an education card that
includes information on that region the
wine is from tasting notes food pairings
and serving temperatures you can always
switch up the amount of reds whites and
roses if you're a seasonal wine drinker
and you can skip an order whenever you
want plus being a bright sellers member
means you get access to their premium
wine portfolio before the wines hit the
market yeah even if you're not a regular
wine drinker this could be the perfect
gift for that special wine lover in your
life and the best part is that if you do
not like a bottle of wine bright cellars
offers a delight guarantee that will
send you a replacement bottle in your
next order for a limited time inside of
you listeners get 50. did you hear me
inside of you listeners get 50 off their
first six bottle box by going to
brightsellers.com
inside it's basically six bottles of
wine for the price of three to get fifty
percent off your first box head to
brightsellers.com that's b r i g h t c e
l l a r s
dot com backslash inside bright cellars
helping you discover wine you will love
inside of you is brought to you by geico
guys don't go anywhere you know geico
you love geico they've been around for a
while everybody uses geico for the love
of god but if you rent or own your home
um you know look i go when i go to the
grocery store i don't go to the grocery
store i have someone deliver my food
i've talked to you about this it's
convenience and geico makes your life so
much easier because they have what's
called bundling policies
your auto insurance your renter's
insurance
or homeowners and you can bundle it
together pay for everything at once it's
so simple even a rose and bomb can do it
and here's all you have to do for this
bundling policy they give you the best
rates they really do geico knows what to
do uh go to geico.com you get a quote
and you see how much you can save it's
really geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com
did you run into any problems where you
went to bed at night and thought what am
i doing i can't do this uh wow that was
a terrible day or uh wow i'm in over my
head i thought i could do this a lot of
that happened um leading up to it and
the week before
um and even sleepless nights
oh
sleepless nights nights uh sleepless
nights sleeping sleep is
yeah but once once um
once i was in it
and started shooting
there wasn't time
to get upset
about anything for too long or
upset about anything at all because you
never lost your cool
no i no i didn't lose my cool i i i
don't think i mean you'd have to ask you
know my lovely wife and lead
bet topher
wait so the wife was a lead
she was oh now come on that doesn't that
had a whole thing because i know that
you
worked with her in brooklyn nine-nine
and you yeah i believe you directed an
episode that she was in no i didn't
direct the ones she was in she was she
was in an episode we we've acted
together before in in the wet hot
american summer series on netflix and we
worked very very well together very well
we hadn't acted in uh you know we didn't
do the actor director thing yet and but
we thought we had a pretty good shot at
that because of the type of people we
are we're we um
you know beth is a incredible actor and
and
doesn't you know require a lot of
um hand-holding you know um that's good
you don't need to be told how great she
is all the time
well i i think every actor including
myself
needs that was i is that am i giving you
what you want yes it's f yeah i think
we're all there including me no but but
you know um
it was helpful because i had a
conversation with all the actors you
know all of whom were friends of mine
except for uh one uh otto sando who was
incredible in this movie and his vibe
was incredible and got along with
everyone great and um but the rest of
the cast i knew well and we had a
conversation about what kind of
production this was going to be which
was one that ran very fast and because
of the logistics of the production um we
wouldn't really have time for a lot of
takes and so they knew that we were
going to move pretty much no your [ __ ]
hit your mark you're still like what
they all did and i said look you know
we're in a tight space a lot of the
movie takes place in this fire tower
it's a 12 foot by 12 foot space there's
enough room for me and the dp who's also
the operator frank um and the actor and
like a sound person how many cameras um
well we used um we used uh
one one camera mini alexa however
you know when you rent a camera they
give you another body just as a backup
and so then we bought extra accessories
to make sure at bare minimum that could
work we couldn't pull focus on it but we
so on heavier days we had two cameras
um but in addition to that we were
shooting second unit um while we're
shooting our our first units and you're
trusting the other guys to do your
second unit yes because we had to and
also the the other guys have were you
know our second unit team
was my uh unit production manager jay
smith who he was out of he's out of
portland
and um he also was a first lady and
second aed on on other movies and so
um i'm sorry second unit director on
other movies so he became like a point
guy but our main guy was this great um
uh camera operator at a spokane named
deshaun bedford and
he would be running b camera on the days
we would run two cameras and then on the
other days he would go out with a
different camera uh either the mini
alexa if we weren't using that or the
black magic 4k and he would do other um
second unit stuff right panasonic gh5
now now i'm really kind of listing all
the this is the nerdy stuff yeah but all
the equipment stuff stuff you're
learning along the way we had a lot of
cameras because we didn't want to miss
anything we did is it is it a scary
movie is it psychological is it is it
paranoid it's it's got to be is it
bloody
yeah there's gore in there it's i think
i think it's a pretty scary movie we'll
see i mean there were um
you know it's about uh it's about a
woman who experienced this violent
assault and she goes to
um to a lookout tower to you know try to
get her life back in order get some
peace of mind and isolation but um
the ptsd and the isolation um does not
give her the
the self-recovery that she was hoping
for and it kind of spins her out so
um
it's uh moves a lot about you know
seeing things that aren't there and uh
what's real what's not and
uh mainly what happens when you don't
get help for
a traumatic event
um that you can't handle on your own to
better help online therapy that's
exactly what you're brought to you by
better i'm telling you they're one of
our sponsors but you know that's true
when you but when you don't get therapy
when you don't work your demons out yeah
these things happen yeah and that's what
happens to her in this movie yeah i mean
there's it goes over a lot of mental
illness in this movie for sure um did
you deal with mental illness as a child
or have family members that dealt with
it um
no i mean i you know i have levels of
like ocd and um
but nothing that
i didn't suffer from um depression or or
anything you've never suffered from any
kind of depression really i've been
depressed for sure but situational
depression yeah yeah it was i was never
too anxious i feel more anxious now that
i'm older than i yeah
what is that why does this happen i
think because you just have more to lose
i mean your the stakes are higher why
um
i think you know more about the world
and how terrible it can be
how like how how many awful things are
in it and how many incredible things are
in it too but you know you're just like
man
you know a lot of the randomness i think
can bring anxiety um
that's true
you know but that's what happens it
seems like the older i get the more
anxious i get the more i care and i'm
like why do you care so much when you
were younger you didn't care so much you
weren't stressed as much yeah you just
kind of filled your days with fun and
and work and just went with the flow
yeah well it's easier to be in the
moment then right do you
when you're working with your wife and
we'll move on here but when you're
working with your is there any times
where she's like joe joe i get it i get
it i get it or you have those moments
and you talk about these moments before
they happen like look we're working
close together i'm directing you i'm
going to say things you're going to get
mad at me i want more i want more i want
more and i'm your husband and this is
going to be odd yeah um we did talk
about it and um you know we got through
it there was only one episode it was
totally my fault and i did i didn't lose
my cool but the the the you know i was
it was in the first two one or it was
like maybe it was day three
um and
we were at the end of the day
and it was completely unprofessional on
my part but i'm going to come clean
because this is what this podcast is
about we're getting inside of me come
clean please i'm going to come clean and
you know was uh and by the way i'll tell
you if it was your fault no it
definitely was my fault
and you know as you know she asked as
any actor would do she's like
what you know what am i
what's what's my action here what am i
supposed to be doing exactly
and i thought it was kind of obvious
what she was supposed to be doing
and i was also it was a long day i was a
little stressed
um and i said your action is
we have 15 minutes to get this shot and
then it's the end of the day
and i was very mortified and ashamed and
she's like okay and and then she did the
action and
it wasn't what i it wasn't right because
i didn't tell her what to do
and we had to kind of reset this kind of
big thing it was totally my fault and
she was so annoyed it had every right to
be
with me but i i effed up for sure in
that moment but i will say that that
really was the only
moment like that throughout the whole uh
show where right and because i've
learned the lesson i'm like just learn
your lesson early i learned it early and
you know and it was during the big
climactic scene at the end and there was
certain you know
pacing of action that i needed and i
just wasn't clear
and
anyway so that was the lesson learned
and other than that we were we were spot
on fantastic i love working with her and
it was great because
you know i wrote the role with her in
mind and i knew that she had all the
levels to play it and then then watching
her do it i'm like man there's still
more there that i didn't see she was
terrific in it how many years ago did
you write this script i i broke the
story broke the story in uh
in this in the spring of 2018
in like march of 2018. so this happened
pretty quickly within three years you
make a movie that's that's rare it's
rare and you know what i was to show you
how like out of touch of with reality i
was i was like i'm going to write it in
march and then this summer i'm going to
shoot it like the summer of 2018. like
an idiot like i just i'm an impatient
person by nature i want to do it now we
got to do it now i've always that's
that's been my burden the cross that
i've have to say and you have a child
eli and and you can't be you have to
learn patience don't you when you have a
child i'm telling you this is going to
be his great lesson to me is
i have to learn it now
and um that's always been a a stick in
the mud for me and um i learned it on
this project for sure even though as you
say
three years is no time
from you know conception to you know end
of production
to get something dodgeball took 12 years
to make no one would buy it no one would
make it right something like 12 years
did you hear that ryan
yeah something like 12 years so
even even the funny movies the hit
movies they take a long time to make and
like you said you got to have a boner
for it you have to say i'm making this
[ __ ] movie yeah i'm making it and you
made it i made it i'm so i'm proud of
you thanks man it's such an achievement
no nobody could take that away from you
you went and made a movie i had a lot of
um i really did have a lot of support
and a lot of friends like yourself and
others that you know um that have been
like you're gonna do it dude you'll get
it done
and uh it was nice to hear that did your
other friends like the guys from the
state who have been your friends since
new york university back in the day yeah
who then you went on to do white hot
american summer and tons of stella yeah
shorts and tons of did they ever get
jealous that oh he's he's the one who
got the hit show in brooklyn nine nine
nine oh he's the one who's going to
direct the movie where's our roles we
give him these roles in red hot you know
what do you mean you don't know i guess
i one i i don't one i don't think so
they're all doing incredibly well i know
it's not like you know they're doing um
they're all so amazingly talented again
this gets back to like surrounding
yourself with people that are better
yeah and
you know uh look jealousy is something
we've all
that's a that's a great
monster it is um we've all dealt with
that yeah we have
um
brooklyn nine-nine i mean how many
seasons is this now
uh
on august 12th
the
eighth season will be premiering on nbc
and
i'm really excited and it's it's strange
coming out of something as
personal uh as outpost um the horror
movie into
this other incredibly
impactful
uh and
ginormous part of my life that's changed
my life brooklyn nine-nine finally
coming to its
eighth season like this season has been
in the making for like
almost two years like almost two years
and
it's got so many things have happened in
the world um our writers have had to
rewrite this
season
at least three times
um based on just covet and black lives
matter and all that based on
and then george floyd and then some
other stuff happened with and so
it was just an endless that's their
their commitment to getting it right and
making it funny is just so impressive to
me
um i would i get back to patients i
wouldn't have the patience for it i'm
like oh enough just nbc just take these
we did this a year ago well they love
the show that much that they rewrote the
entire season they really did how many
episodes uh we did ten episodes and
you're done this is it unfortunately
until you know whatever reunion happens
which i'm sure it will at some point but
how emotional is that for you on your
last day of shooting
very vividly yeah very vividly it was uh
you know all day is filled you you get
to the lot and all day it's just filled
with anticipation everyone knows
that it's gonna end today and so all the
scenes that you're doing
there's kind of like you're trying to be
present but it's really about like soon
the final scene's coming up the final
scene is coming up the final thing it's
going to come up and so
you know it was uh truly great to have
everyone there and uh and and feel that
out and then then that scene comes
and uh
you know i can't give uh any of it away
but i'll say that
it was very difficult to uh for the eyes
not to stay wet during the scene
because the scene is uh is very close to
what was happening in real life
and um
and there was just this palpable like
pulsating in the room
um so during the shot there's like this
moment during the scene there's this
moment and
we're all making eye contact and it's
truly
oh i get emotional thinking about it was
so intense and and then it ends and um
you know the where it really sank in is
like before the take started our um
um
one of our uh
crew members i could also tell you like
like the emotion on you that you're just
i could see you oh
you're you're going back i'm going back
in and trying to resist let it go our
yeah our our uh
our ac chris
you know um
hits the clap stick and you hear you
hear our director claire claire scanlan
directed the last one and she's like um
you know um
it's like phil widen out you know to to
get like the wide
you know shot um
and
you know chris is he's like nine nine
forever slaps a stick
and and 99 forever is that the only time
he said that that's the only time that
was sad yeah forever and you know on a
clapstick on the slate and uh and
everyone's like here we go
and so you know we we've run we run it
for a long time we don't really um
we don't really uh cut a lot we're just
like rolling and rolling and rolling so
we knew this is it like before the cut
before you're cut
that's what you would hear
that's how they would do it right and i
said blow your ears out sorry um that uh
we knew th this was gonna be it so
anyway um
uh that happens
you know we do hear cut there's this big
uh big exhale and roar and clap and and
applause and
hugs
um but quick hugs because it's coveted
[Laughter]
hugs with six foot long arms right and
um we all go outside
you know um because there's gonna be a
nice um
there's a podium out there and everyone
is six feet apart and listening to
our
dp rick page and our creator dan gore
and
just say a few words and then
the thing i was most not prepared for
was uh
you know when they wrap you out as an
actor
and you're they're just going up the
call sheet you know and they're like
joel mckinnon miller that's her that's a
series rap on joel mckittle and kennan
miller and everyone's just like oh no oh
and i i was just not i couldn't keep it
together once it got to me i mean you
were gone oh i was i lost it i was just
like you know you hear your name
you know said for the last time on a
show that has
brought so much you know
wealth and joy wealth i say that
financially and
emotionally and spiritually to your life
that
and that you're so grateful you're just
filled with this gratitude and you can't
believe it's over
um and you know you're gonna still be in
touch with um with everyone but it'll be
different you know or you know we're not
gonna see each other every day and all
of that heaviness all that truth is just
coming down it's just raining on you
like oh you're like just
you're just trying so you really lost it
you're crying you're like really crying
yeah absolutely yeah were there anyone
who it was like it was sandberg
emotional everyone was about everyone
there wasn't one person who was kind of
stoic everyone who was happy that it was
[ __ ] over maybe andre brower
he was like yes
no
no everyone everyone in their own way
like you could read their eyes like it
wasn't all tears but by body language or
just their look or how i mean every
everyone you felt
knew the magnitude of the end and what
was really nice is that you know after
that happened
a few of us
put our mask back on and we went into
the bullpen for the last time and we
went out on the kind of rooftop
the fake rooftop out there and just
reminisced a little bit in a quieter um
area you know it wasn't the everyone it
was just the cast and a couple of the
writers
and we just talked about uh
you know favorite episodes and memories
and it was a beautiful end and we
finally left around
10 p.m where
we knew
that you walked off the set and then
that was it the pneumatic drills were
going to be heard in the morning
though everything was coming down apart
taken apart it was all going to go down
you're looking at it for the last time
and you're just like wow this place is
forever in my head
and
i hope that all the moments
that i had over the past eight years are
in a secure place up in the up in the
noggin that i can remember because this
is it all this tangible stuff that goes
away tomorrow morning and that's it and
it was intense man did you cry to your
wife
oh my god i came home
and i
literally collapsed into beth's arms and
like literally hitch sobbed like oh
just got it i was like it was out yeah
man it felt great it felt great
inside of you is brought to you by
better help boy this company has helped
so many people it's helped me it's
helped ryan here uh if you don't know
about better help just listen up if
you're dealing with any kind of
depression anxiety work overload you got
a lot on your mind you just need to get
it out um ryan we've talked about this
you're still doing better help still
doing better health still helping you
you seem like in better spirit i'm not
just saying that but you you can tell
better help helps you get better it
really does it really does and i like
these guys they've stuck with me because
i think it's working i think people are
listening and you know i noticed a lot
of my patrons you know they'll respond
like hey betterhelp's really cool thanks
thanks for introducing me to it and um
it's just one of those sponsors that's
it's not even a hard sell it's like you
know it's so easy to like do you want to
feel better about yourself do you want
to
fix things that you don't like about
yourself better help better help is
there
if you're feeling depressed or
struggling with uncertainty or having
difficulty sleeping better help offers
experienced therapists who can listen
and they can help and you can start
communicating in 48 hours or less
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas the service is
available for clients worldwide you can
log into your account anytime send a
message to your counselor and you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they'll make it
easy and free to change counselors if
needed you know if you have did you have
to change a counselor i did but that was
only because he left the service oh he
left the service okay well there you go
i mean that's the thing you meet
somebody a lot of times you're like ah
i'm not comfortable with this person
right it's so easy you just change
they'll help you change immediately and
it and this is common this happens you
might meet the therapist of your of your
life
you know but you will you'll find the
right one uh it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available and that's
for damn sure um so many people have
been using betterhelp they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
don't even take my word for it just do
it take ryan's word for it if you want
because
we really believe in this in this place
better help online therapy and here's
all you have to do it's pretty easy
inside you is sponsored by better help
online therapy and our listeners get 10
percent off their first month of online
therapy at betterhelp.com
inside
that's
p dot betterhelp.com slash
inside
get matched with a better help therapist
and get started inside of you is brought
to you by m1 finance the finance super
app this all-in-one app makes it easy as
pie to invest borrow and spend exactly
how you want build a portfolio of stocks
or etfs in minutes
with their intuitive pies interface or
use a pre-build expert pie that invests
according to your goals investing
involves risks and m1 helps you invest
according to your risk tolerance borrow
against your portfolio with some of the
lowest rates on the market then use it
however you want keep in mind borrowing
increases your risk and rates may vary
or stash your cash in their free digital
checking account it's fast it's easy and
it saves you tons of time and time
is money
switch to a sleeker easier and better
way to manage your money plus get a 30
bonus to your m1 invest account when you
get approved and fund it with 1 000
within your first 14 days it's easy just
go to m1 finance dot com slash inside of
you for more info
that's m the number one
finance dot com
terms and conditions apply
[Music]
i mean when you rewind and you go back
to the first day on set eight years ago
do you ever i mean because no one ever
thinks this is going to last eight
seasons you know you're like i'm lucky
to be here
we think as actors we're gonna be fired
tomorrow right this is it uh they're
gonna see the dailies they're gonna say
yeah they're gonna find out the truth
they're gonna find out the truth we
always do that
i mean so you had no thought of like is
there something special here when did it
click that this is special
um
you know i we we uh
i put this because i i no one knew it
was gonna go eight years i'll say that i
knew
you know from having been part of
um other great collaborations where the
cast clicked that i knew it was going to
be fun and i knew it was going to be
good
that i knew
so i knew that
i didn't know if it would be good with
the audience if people would like it but
i knew it would be something we'd like
we being the cast and
friends of mine that are like-minded
i don't think it became something
special um really
until we got canceled and picked up i
mean i feel like that's when
for me the kind of what was that season
six that was after season five after
season after season five so once that
happened i felt that
the show
took on
kind of a mythical new chapter of this
this phoenix that was raised from the
ash and that became the story of
brooklyn nine-nine because you know we
were all over the news and you know more
people were suddenly uh in tune and
aware of this this show
than it or they had ever been when it
was on the air and so
that's for me i think when
um
you saw the power of uh of the people
that watched the show the fans of how
important it was to them and
how five years of what we were trying to
do
which was not like
this is how it should be it's more like
wouldn't it be great if it was like this
the you know police force you know and
that's always been the uh approach
that that resonated with a lot of other
people people that whether
i don't think anyone really believed it
could be that but
um they
believed in the desire for it to be like
that and i think that was very powerful
for a lot of people wow i mean when a
show's canceled
i've never been on a show that was even
reconsidered like you know you get
cancelled small bill get cancelled never
got cancelled never got cancelled okay
so i mean if something gets canceled
99.9 percent of the time it's done yeah
yeah you know sometimes they go well
let's shop it around other networks it
never happens
name three shows that it's done yeah
it's happening you just can't really do
that
did happen with scrubs
did it happen with scrubs yeah scrubs
went to abc like after uh
that was after like eight that was after
like eight or nine it was like i think
they'll end of it right right i think it
happened with
happy endings right
i can't remember happening but happy
endings didn't last that much it didn't
but i thought that might have jumped too
but to be canceled in the future let's
teach you your point yes not not often
it doesn't really
were you like this is done you never
thought in a million years this is gonna
get picked up again
oh yeah we i was i was um
yeah
i was moving on and um
uh not celebrating is not the right word
but i was kind of with friends and
you know raising a glass to what great
things that the show had brought and to
be grateful and everything ends and you
know and then suddenly it was alive well
i know how you think because i think
that way but when the show's over now
after eight seasons and it's about to
premiere
of course you're thinking about your
next job now right
well yes although you know i've i knew
that this year was going to be
completely um committed to outpost that
i didn't really think too much about
what's next because
the movie was so important to me but
also i i don't know i was just hoping
that and still do that
you know i i've i put i got a pretty
good foot in the door now i would think
after
a show
like brooklyn nine-nine and part of me
was worried that like hey man you're
gonna lose your heat hey man you gotta
jump from one thing to another you got
you got your you got you gotta lose your
heat and then that i kicked that voice
out out of my head right um pretty
quickly
um
but yeah i don't i honestly don't know
what my next job is are you doing reno
9-1-1 oh man
you want to hear something really sad
yeah is that i mean i know you don't
want to hear something sad i they're
starting shooting today
um on um and you just couldn't be there
i couldn't be there because i jump into
my
edit tomorrow i thought you're going to
say because of the podcast you really
you really ruined the whole [ __ ]
thing man
you really blew it i'm doing your
podcast tom carrey but you're working on
the movie so you have a certain like
when you're done with a movie you have
like a couple of weeks of editing and uh
it sounds like a month like right so you
couldn't do it and they wanted you to do
it of course and i wanted to do it they
were so spectacular and um here's the
connection there so um the dp my dp uh
frank pereira also is shooting reno so
frank went you know to idaho and did
outpost with me on this mountain this
crazy shoot rested for a week we just
got back a week ago and now he's jumping
in to do reno they do that talk about a
hero talk about him the strength to do
that well he's incredible he's just
truly um
he's just great and he's gonna crush it
on reno too and he he had shot um the
last season of reno as well when uh the
one that i um was on the season eight i
think or maybe season seven whatever the
last one was
but they're doing a movie now and i miss
those guys so much and uh the whole gang
i mean we had such a blast when we did
the show on the now defunct quibby um
but now but but those i think those
episodes are now being redone to
premiere on uh somewhere else do you
want to jump on another series would you
rather continue doing movies would you
what is it do you want to do it all
right here's what i'd like to do rosie
i'd love to
do a show for a few months a year and
make a little bit of money
and then just finance my movies because
you know what was really nice
is uh
being able to hire who you want
and um being in charge being in a way uh
in in charge yeah
you like being in control because in a
lot of ways your whole life not to say
you haven't had control but you're the
studio is is is you know yeah
hanging over yeah the money people yeah
they're the money people oh you want me
to do this movie you're the boss i'm
just the guy who's coming on the show
yeah oh it's always like that but this
and that's okay i mean that's i like
doing that too sometimes but like for
at least for this first movie i'm like
if it's gonna be my first maybe only one
who knows how it's gonna turn out i
gotta fail my own way like if it's gonna
not work i gotta make sure it's because
of me and not because someone else was
you know making creative decisions that
i disagreed with right um and so that
was a big plus but it was also nice just
to
um get to understand low budget
filmmaking and like you you see behind
the curtain you get you peek under every
rock you understand every dynamic every
person that uh has to uh
be uh hired to make this movie
and how one person can bring the whole
ship down if they're bad or if they're
not doing their job i mean we were lucky
it was just me and two other people
financing this movie people so it was
nice three human beings not this like
all right so 350 thousand dollars
no i'm not
but it was nice to have
um
you know a smaller investment group sure
as well anyway i mean
i um i learned a lot on this well let me
ask you this
you're not going to dictate
based on this
movie's the outcome of this movie let's
say outpost hopefully it's a it's a
smash hit it's a it's great it gets
received well but you're not going to
make a decision on bait on directing
again and doing another movie if the
movie just does doesn't do well in his
car yeah you don't like it yeah yeah
exactly i i mean i i think
you know i think i'm gonna i loved dude
you loved it i loved it so i definitely
want to do it again and we're just gonna
see whether i really will the only way
i'm going to do it again is if i do pay
it for it because no one's going to give
me any money or whether it's different
whether like hey that was great yeah
we'll help you finance this movie i i
just i had a great time man and i want
to work with those people again as well
as old friends that i have worked with
um
for a long time i just it was a very
rewarding experience
and um i can't wait what uh what a year
i mean it's the last season you go
through this emotional wave of
a wave of emotion and through brooklyn
999 you direct your first feature that
you've been wanting to do that's your
passion you've loved horror movies since
a kid you direct this movie now you're
going in a post i mean what probably the
biggest year of your life
in many ways yeah yeah well it was going
to be a yeah i knew it was going to be a
pretty big year with the ending of
brooklyn i-9 and and outpost finally
happening for sure what was your uh look
ryan was a big fan of brooklyn nine-nine
yeah how many episodes did you watch all
of them you've seen every one of them
yeah what's your favorite one um
i don't know but i can remember like the
specific bit that got me into it uh was
when you dropped the muffin oh it was
one of the funniest things i'd seen that
year
it was just it was just like a really
like funny scene like just the way you
said i don't know it's like it's not the
way you said muffin muffin in my head
but yeah yeah
he slams his head into a counter it's
great i uh thanks man i i was sent
someone sent me a video of their
like four-year-old child
it might have been david
miner or maybe his grand
daughter i can't remember anyway i
digress but but this toddler was
imitating
that moment and it was the most adore
and she wasn't really doing it she was
just kind of like
there was a pillow and she'd do a pillow
and be like my head my my muffin my head
my muffin she would just go back and
forth but it was the most adorable thing
it was it was just really well done i
was really really happy to see it yeah
uh this is called uh [ __ ] talking
with joe i'm gonna this is i'm terrible
at this this is great these are just
from uh these are just from fans my
patrons my level patrons oh nice who if
you want to join patreon patreon.com
inside you but they have questions okay
emily asks what was your favorite
episode to film in brooklyn nine-nine
nine-nine
you know that's very that's very hard
there's 153 of them right but you have
to remember that most of them i've
forgotten um okay so those weren't the
ones
no i'll say um um
yeah i i don't know i'm sorry emily
there was a lot i i well this this
season
um i can't talk about this season
there's a bunch this season that i'm
really excited about that's not some of
your favorite stuff some of my yeah
honestly like there's some great great
very fun episodes um in this upcoming
season when was it did you think that
they're like not to say you weren't
funny but joe latruglio we got to give
him more and more when did you see that
start to happen
oh
wow i mean was it from the bat or do you
think they really started building your
character more as the seasons went on
i tell you um as soon as i saw that i
was not number one on the call shoot i
had an issue and i was it was for it was
an uphill battle from that point saying
listen man number six needs some bits
number six needs some
happen that bits happen you know and so
that's when they knew like oh boy yeah
we're in for it we're in fire steph a
who will you this is a tough question i
don't think you'll answer it honestly to
be honest with you
what's the funniest no who will you miss
most from brooklyn nine-nine i can't
answer can you name the top two i can no
i can't no i cannot
uh but you do have someone in your head
that you will miss the most
in your mind that you won't say i have
like
i have like as soon as one comes into my
head another three like pop i'm like oh
man
you know and
it's it's not a fair question uh it's
it's a heart i could tell you who i
missed the most when i left my show yeah
who i'm gonna talk about yeah it's hard
right it is hard yeah no i think um i
miss my my makeup
artist oh that's nice to say she was
always she was like my mother i saw i i
was with her hours you know putting the
makeup on and all this stuff and like
you know the head stuff yeah i just
remember like i'm gonna miss her
i'm gonna miss her the most because i
spent the most time with her and she
she knew my whole life she was like fam
she was really family yeah but cast
members that's that's difficult we all
got so tight i mean we we really did i
mean you know there are some that i will
see more than others because
you know like terry's very busy andre's
on the you know east coast
um but andy and steph and and melissa
and chelsea i feel like i'll see those
guys
leanne p you know she knows that you're
directing a horror movie as a horror
film psychological thriller movie fan
herself she was wondering what some of
your favorite horror films were ah
that's a great question well i'll lead
with um the brood um david cronenberg
yeah that's my favorite wow and um
i love all his stuff but that's about
the movie to your right we just talked
about underrated movies oh well
returning living dead i love that movie
too i love the humor in that movie um
you know you gotta you got a lot in here
rosie that i love the thing is up there
for sure
you know the um outpost was uh there's a
few movies that influenced that uh
repulsion was one of them the shiny
uh invasion of the body snatchers 78.
look at you going into
emilyville
79.
a lot of zooms in that one yeah and they
that house i miss those old zooms did
you do some of that you're getting
they're coming back in outposts yeah
thank god i love those things i love the
whole you know the pans and the the the
uh the tilts and the zooms and the got
all of them we got all these i mean we
got the t's we got the p's we got the
z's baby
they had they took their time with it
um
the chief wants to know the funniest
shenanigan off-camera moment on the set
of super bad do you remember anything
really funny happening on superbad i
mean you weren't you were there a bit
i i i was there a bit um
man
gosh uh it's been a while i know it's
been a while like we we had a lot of um
i just remember it was very chill that
set uh i had just that's where i met
bill hader for the first time
and um what a genius he is he is when he
does that impression from dateline keith
morrison uh-huh
oh it just kills me he's he's great i
met you know i met really all those guys
there i had known the director greg
matola he had we had traveled in the
same circles when we lived in new york
in the mid 90s
um
yeah what uh i i remember that i was
super nervous
because there was going to be a lot of
improv in the scene where uh
i i hit jonah hill with the car
you know that whole
that whole scene is just like
i don't know maybe it was like maybe a
half a page or maybe a page of dialogue
and there was just
you know judd i wanted to keep us going
and and greg wanted to keep us going
and
you know i was just motor mouth because
that was a lot of just nerves luckily it
came out funny um that was fun to do i
mean that that scene was great what
about when it doesn't come out funny
does the director say hey yeah get rid
of all that stuff no i think they just
know the director would be like well
i'll cut that but you know you know
you know i i think uh
directors probably shouldn't be like
that wasn't funny don't do that
or that didn't work i mean people say
yeah hey let's try something different
let's try something different you say
you say you say like all right great we
got that you know
and then you say you're the big director
over here he said we got that that was
great that was great great jobs you're
alive you're a lying
no no we did get that though we did get
it i remember i watched um a
a guy that i knew uh a guy that i knew
years ago there was a
guy that i traveled in the same circle
with he was a friend but not a friend
but kind of a friend friend enough where
i had to not lie to him and he went up
and did uh
stand up
and it was just
just horrendous it was a failure and um
and he was tone deaf he didn't really
get it like he didn't and he comes off
and he's he's pretty happy he's like
he's like yeah man what do you think i
just
held took a beat when like
man you really went for it with a big
smile
like and he did and that's what i did
and he's like yeah yeah that was that's
a positive way to approach it because
some people
some actors yeah if you approach them
with like yeah that's your energy's
completely wrong everything's and some
directors don't give a [ __ ] they'll say
that i did i did i did uh this really
here's a funny story uh to my dear
friend ken marino um he's gonna be in
the podcast oh great ken you have to ask
him about this because so so he gets
this pile this is like in 96 97 and um
you know we've done the state but no one
really knows where we got this pilot and
i went to go watch it like live it was
like uh i think mark ruffalo was in it
too it was like the great cast
and um i was in the audience and
i cannot believe i did this and just
know when i did this know that it really
was coming from a place of like wanting
trying to give notes so
he's on the soundstage i am you know in
the bleachers that they have in the
sound stage you've been there but for
those that don't know you know they they
bring a bunch of people in and you watch
this live taping it's a three camera
show and you know they do a scene and
then they're like cut and then they kind
of move stuff around and between takes
you know the actors if they want could
go up to the bleachers and you know talk
to their friends or parents
so ken
looks over after take and he kind of
does like you know shrugs his shoulder
and looks at me like like like how'd i
do like you know hands out like what do
you think and i
i
i go
uh and i and i i i till my i give like a
with my hand like an okay i'm trying to
describe for the listeners like an okay
with the hand not an okay sign like
like what would you call it like you did
till now
like this but then i go then i then i
then i turn like i'm turning him down no
no turn it up so i turn the volume like
signal turning the volume dial and then
giving a thumbs up like turn it up
basically it was okay turn it up
his face
his face was like
what like like like he was not ready to
to kind of hear
you know
nothing other than like great man all
good was he mad he wasn't mad i think he
was like he was like
oh okay okay like i don't know it was
really like of course he was terrific
but i just wanted i guess
97 1997 joe wanted more at the time out
of ken marino
for that take
i guess you just he could have given a
little bit more you know
um could you imagine oh that is
hilarious can you imagine your friend
you invite your friend for support and
you're like listen come on and and
you're like hey turn it up a bit come on
you can do better than that bigger you
have bigger is better you have to ask
them about you remind me of that oh my
god
what a treat
uh you know and i love you man sebastian
wants to know the part you played was
specifically written for you the
high-pitched voice still kills him today
oh
thanks brian uh no it wasn't it wasn't
sebastian
what did you say i said ryan oh that's
sitting next to me yeah thanks thanks
about thanks ryan
thanks alan anyway
um
no it was not written for me that was
just um
uh a choice that um the john hamburg had
for the character how many choices do
you think you make on average that you
improvise something and it gets in
i would say per scene i'd probably make
about
about 89 choices per scene you know
and i'll you know the first first 40 are
within the first few lines and then you
know the rest
you'll get about 20 uh when there's i'm
not talking i'll make 20 choices with my
face that you wouldn't be able to tell
but i'm making them and then the last
part is where their choices really uh
come into play really i i closed i
closed with about uh three choices at
one time do you
do you ever while you're on set whether
it's brooklyn nine-nine or whatever yeah
do something you're like i just i was
not great in that scene yes often um and
then move on yeah yeah i'll uh uh a
couple times i've um i've done like well
we didn't get that um but we're gonna
move on and um i'm not that proud of
that i and it was because i had only
made 50 choices that time at the 89. do
you say that out loud like do you ever
mention that or you just move on you
don't you ever like comment on you're
like well we're going to move on but i
wasn't good so
yeah yeah people they'll move on to like
you know the kind of break room set and
also being the bullpen being like well
didn't get that one guys
swung and missed on that one guys
like joe come on in we gotta you know do
a quick blocking rehearsal yep didn't
get it still still thinking about the
other scenario about the other side
we've done that before i have nightmares
about a scene they're like why did i do
it like that why didn't i have more
confidence why didn't i yeah do you ever
feel like that like all of a sudden your
confidence level for one scene's down
then it was up on another yeah often
usually after lunch
my confidence is down
you're tired you had too much parmesan
yeah i just got up from a nap i'm like
ah man
where's my expressa you know
well this is a treat listen i i i love
having you on i'm glad you came on i'm
so excited to see you on the big horror
movie man so if you if you ever want to
screen it in the basement here oh my god
if you ever want to like if i can come
to a screening i'd love to absolutely
whatever you need for me thank you man
i'd love to come back and talk about it
more
uh once we're done i want i would love
that i can't i cannot wait to see thanks
man i mean people don't realize what it
takes to make a movie and a low budget
movie under a million dollars and you're
shooting up in the mountains and you
know you make your dreams come true and
and i and i love seeing you make your
dreams come true thanks buddy i
appreciate it thank you very much ryan
you got anything you want to say to joe
no thanks just for you know being around
thanks man i enjoy i enjoy watching you
and stuff you're it's always uh it's
always real well
sebastian it was nice sitting next to
you
[Laughter]
i love you matt thanks for letting me be
inside of you thanks man all right buddy
bye
uh there you go uh wonderful man um i
wish him the best in all his endeavors
and uh brooklyn nine-nine the final
season make sure you watch it tune in
um thanks for uh staying here with us
thanks for tuning in every week um as
ryan said the handles are at
insideypodcast on instagram and twitter
and at inside oh no at insidetv podcast
on instagram and facebook and at
insideipod on twitter
uh you can join patreon if you want to
help the podcast in other ways my lovely
patreons really give back in more ways
than one patreon.com inside of you uh
stageit.com you can see my band sunspin
play it's rob my uh guitarist's birthday
my partner in crime and you can also go
to sunspin.com and get tickets if that's
easier
but
uh before we uh let you go here today
and i i thank you sincerely for tuning
in and uh again if you like the podcast
please subscribe it helps the podcast so
much there's so many other podcasts but
if you're liking this one if you enjoyed
my candid conversations ryan what would
you say how would you urge people to
listen uh did you like what just where
to go no just like why would you listen
what's the [ __ ] podcast
uh because you have some good
conversations some deeper conversations
that uh sort of go beyond just uh
acting or show business it like you know
it starts there but it always you know
because that's some interesting stuff
that's the juicy stuff but then you get
into some
real talks and uh
they they can offer you some insight on
how people live uh it might help you yes
it helps me and i'm sure it helps a lot
of other people out there so thanks for
that
let's read the top tier patrons these
are patrons who give back during the top
tier they give back uh a lot to the
podcast and i'm gonna read their names
off that's one of the perks they get to
hear their names read off here we go
nancy d leah s trisha sarah v little
lisa yukiko jill e bryan h mama lauren g
nico p jeffrey w i'm sorry it's jerry w
not jeffrey
robert l
jason w or is that robert i robert i
robert i jason w apothean kristen k
amelia oh alison l raj c joshua d emily
s
cjp samantha m jennifer n stacy l gen s
jamal f janelle b carey b tab with the
272 not to be confused with the 273.
kimberly mike eldon soprano 99 more
ramirez santiago m sarah f chad w leanne
p janine r maya r maya p matty s shannon
d belinda and kevin v james r chris h
dave h spiderman chase sheila g
brad d ray h tabitha t lillian a
michelle
k nice way to jump in there michael s
talia m betsy d claire m laura l chad l
rochelle nathan e marion meg k janelle p
trav l dan n lorraine g carrie h
veronica k big stevie w
kendall t angel m rhiannon c uh corey k
super sam
coleman g deb nexon michelle a liz l liz
i i guess
jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gavinator and h david c ellie m john b
brandy d yvore r camille s bano urbano
the c joey m willie f kristina en
adelaide
and welcome newcomers welcome all new
patrons and a love you to all the
patrons out there who support the
podcast in so many different ways
you mean the world to me big shout out
to my editor jason you're doing a
fantastic job big shout out to ryan here
my engineer my main man my side man and
crime the side man side man in crime
and big bryce uh thank you cumulus for
supporting the podcast and everyone that
listens uh be good to yourselves um
thank you for allowing me to be inside
each and every one of you today from the
hollywood hills in california i'm
michael rosenbaum uh brian taylor's
hollywood california a little wave ryan
and we'll see you next time we'll see on
the flip side enjoy your week be good to
yourselves
[Music]